cuando los extraña demasiado pascal
contempla sus fotos para hace magia esta
es mi hija embarazada aquí está con su
bebé y estos son los niños pequeños que
se fueron de francia
si los dos están ahora en un campo en el
norte de siria la hija de pascal se fue
en 2015 para integrarse a la
organización estado islámico siguiendo a
su pareja de esa época con sus tres
hijos
ya nació otro desde entonces para acá él
vive constantemente preocupada por sus
nietos temo por ellos claro están en la
cárcel desde hace uno o dos años y medio
en condiciones deplorables un gesto
político sería suficiente decir si vamos
a salvar esos niños no son pequeños
terroristas o pequeños yihadistas son
niños
para transmitir este mensaje pascal se
reúne con un colectivo de familias ese
día de septiembre se agrupan delante del
ministerio de solidaridad y salud para
interpelar al presidente de la república
y sus niños regresaron a clase la semana
pasada los nuestros no han conocido
nunca la escuela con esos niños
simbolizados con estas maletas son sus
nietos nietas o sobrinos retenidos en
síria con sus madres y cadistas desde la
caída del autodenominado grupo de estado
islámico en 2019 entre 200 y 250 niños
franceses viven en estos campos sobre
poblados y cosas para algunos de esos
pequeños es el tercer invierno que pasan
a menos de 10 grados en tiendas de
campaña y a cielo abierto estamos
construyendo y manteniendo a los niños
en esas cárceles a cielo abierto no es
posible si se tiene miedo de repatriar
es porque se cree que son los hijos de
unos adultos que son responsables por
haberse ido al xiria o tal vez por haber
cometido actos que efectivamente le
competen a la justicia es así entonces
que los judíos pero en un país
traumatizado por los atentados cometidos
en nombre del grupo de estado islámico
el regreso de esos niños es motivo de
preocupación en una encuesta realizada
en febrero el 67 por ciento de los
franceses se declara
en contra una piedra en el zapato del
gobierno francés que por ahora se
mantiene en su política de casos
individuales sólo los niños gravemente
enfermos los huérfanos o los niños cuya
madre acepta separarse de ellos pueden
volver una posición contraria a la
convención europea de los derechos
humanos y a la convención internacional
de los derechos de los niños ratificada
por francia ésta le concede en
particular a cada niño el derecho a ser
alimentado y protegido de las
enfermedades y de la violencia de las
convenciones humanitarias adquieren
todos sus sentidos
todos los niños que están en estos
campos
situaciones de violencia y multas son
personas que la palabra perfectamente
recuperable merecen pasmo la media
de jong que son personas que pueden
hacer parte de la sociedad y de ser
miembros activos de la sociedad pero es
necesario quererle hay que darle la mano
lo que hay que hacer el esfuerzo
la voluntad política y fuego la voluntad
política una voluntad de la que francia
ya dio prueba desde marzo de 2019 28
niños franceses han sido repatriados de
manera individual por razones
humanitarias una vez de regreso esos
niños quedan a cargo de la ayuda social
para la infancia y son ubicados en una
familia de acogida educadores psicólogos
jueces infantiles se pone en marcha un
dispositivo muy desarrollado
hay muchos adultos trabajando con esos
niños nuestro trabajo es asegurarnos de
que esos niños estén seguros que sus
necesidades fundamentales sean atendidas
y dureza acompañe
buscas que acompañarlos hasta que
quienes toman las decisiones crean que
ese acompañamiento se puede terminar
y también un trabajo que toma tiempo
para niños que han vivido experiencias
dolorosas
aunque esos traumas pueden reaparecer
años después puede ser que alguno de los
padres haya muerto allá lo cual es un
verdadero tema un padre ha muerto como
héroe para un adolescente
eso significa muchas cosas entonces el
paso a la adolescencia es un verdadero
asunto pero ocurre igual que para
cualquier niño que llega a la
adolescencia cada uno tiene sus
propiedades de problemas aire
dificultades de la que pascal es muy
consciente lo cual no le impide seguir
esperando
imagino buenos momentos como los que
tuve con los que nacieron en francia
antes de que se fueran imagino mi papel
como abuelo simplemente hablando con
ellos jugando con ellos haciendo bromas
[Música]
pascal espera obtener algún día la
custodia de sus nietos sabe que si su
hija también regresa será detenida y
juzgada